this was a long hard battle into the
heart of islamic state's evil-filled
corps
even on the outskirts of raqqa the
fighting was intense destructive
and deadly
it's an eerie drive into a major town
now utterly empty of civilians
in any form of life other than soldiers
the fighting has only stopped in the
last few days
most of raqqa is now a silent witness to
the force needed to destroy an
organization that planned murder and
mayhem from here
across the world
methodically as they can the forces of
the victorious multi-ethnic sdf
use armoured bulldozers supported by
armored trucks
to push into the rubble-filled streets
they'll be hitting mines and booby traps
here for weeks
when isis first came to these areas they
made like a big propaganda
and this showed the bestiality of isis
the cruciality of isis to here and
everybody believed oh isis will not be
defeated
but now it was the opposite we could
defeat isis
so everybody took part in in this
operation
in this liberation and now it's it's
liberated the destruction in the center
is quite incredible
the combination of airstrikes artillery
and street to street fighting
an extraordinary demonstration of
demolition
we're in the process of annihilating
islamic state
in raqqa they've annihilated
pretty much all the city as well but
this is hugely significant what has
happened here
in this roundabout is where bodies
would be left after being executed in
the streets of
it are where internet cafes where
british jihadists like janae hussein
oversaw
the caliphate's media wing if you like
and planned attacks
against the united kingdom in europe and
also
to try and bring about this ideology of
islamic state hatred across the world
well they've all gone now
islamic state's not entirely finished
for certain but here at least
they're definitely finished
while it is far from safe here there are
wild celebrations amongst the fighters
they're world famous now but the female
brigades of the kurdish ypj
really are quite something they've been
a constant and equal part of the victory
here
and in all the various battles this was
their chance
to enjoy their own celebrations and
their opportunity
to remember their dead as well amongst
them britain kimmy taylor
the fighter she's pretty famous here and
around the world as well now this
victory
she believes sends a message to everyone
everywhere
if women understand how to protect
themselves
how to defend themselves physically and
also mentally this is how we gain
freedom
this is it's not just for here it's for
all over the world we need to learn
why we're protecting ourselves what are
we protecting our morals as women
as our ethics as women in our history as
our in our culture as women this is what
we need to protect and we defend it
and from this we can build something new
where we
can build an equal society islamic state
is not finished as an
entity for sure its evil ideologies have
leached across the planet through social
media
and hate-filled sermons but they've been
smashed here
in cabana and mosul and now raqqa
the costs have been terrible but islamic
state
has lost it's quite something to report
stuart ramsey sky news wrecker